[Music]
often we'll make decisions for an
emotional state we'll make decisions at
the end of the day when we're rushed
we'll make decisions afterward irritated
by a colleague or pastured all day about
something one of the ways that we can
alleviate that sort of burden is just to
go for a walk does this decision need to
be made right now if I go for a walk is
that gonna change things if I wait till
tomorrow morning though the old anecdote
or the old advice to sleep on it
actually has a meaningful impact on
dampening our emotions our motion spike
and that's a signal to us that
something's wrong or something's
important to us we often view sort of
intensity as a gauge of how important
those emotions are to us you know we'll
do these things in the moment because
we're emotional and then we sort of
regret it but then we also have to
defend our actions right so we have this
this sort of like dueling inside of our
head where it's like yeah I shouldn't
have done that but yeah I was really mad
and I you know I needed to express
myself and so we sort of like justify
our own behavior it's really strange
well reduce the impact of those emotions
so we want to reduce sort of what's
going on in the current moment we want
to get a better perspective on the
problem and to get distance from a
problem it helps to go for a walk it
helps to take time away from the problem
just sleep on it to look at it in the
morning or what I often do is I mentally
decide here's my decision now I'm gonna
sleep on it then I'll wake up in the
morning and be like how do I feel about
that decision because I'll trick myself
into having made it and if I have
regrets that's a sign that I might want
to think about that problem a lot more
and if I'm comfortable with that
decision then that's a sign that I'm
probably on the right track if I made
the same decision when I'm emotionally
engaged and what I'm not but often you
don't want to decide you just want to
delay that decision why do you have to
make it now another way that we make bad
decisions or that we trick ourselves
into making bad decisions is that we
just look for information that confirms
to what we already believe if people
disagree with us how can they be right
because that means that we're not right
so our ego doesn't often let this
information
it doesn't process it but what we want
to do is what Charles Darwin used to do
we want to pull out at a journal and
every time that something disconfirms of
what we we believe what we know to be
ourselves to be true we want to make a
note of it and we want to start thinking
about it because what we're really
focused on is outcomes we're not focused
on being right or focused on being how
do we create the best outcome possible
and every time that something
disconfirms was something that we think
or we believe that's an opportunity to
learn maybe they're right maybe they're
not but to dismiss it out of hand
without evaluating it is not doing
ourselves justice towards outcomes and
finally overconfidence is one of the
other ways that we sort of lead
ourselves astray we take out size for
risk we believe that we have information
that other people don't have which
causes us to be overconfident to do
things that we otherwise wouldn't do
there's a couple of ways to address
being overconfident one is just to
recall all the times you failed and if
you haven't failed then that's a problem
but often we were very confident we if
you calibrate your decisions if I keep a
decision journal for example and I write
down here's what I think is gonna happen
here's why I think it's gonna happen and
often we get the outcomes we want but
not for the reasons that we thought we
were gonna get and it's an effective
calibration on what you know it's an
effective calibration against your
overconfidence because you realize that
how much we don't actually know or how
much we're right and it's not for the
right reasons I may get the right
outcome but it's not for the reasons
that we predicted that outcome wouldn't
happen by and another way to like sort
of address overconfidence is just have
people check and balance you right which
is no I disagree with you and if we keep
track of when people disagree with us is
the opportunity for learning and
exploring like why is it you disagree is
it you disagree with the variables that
I think are relevant in this particular
situation do you disagree with how I
think those variables interact in this
situation or do you disagree with my
conclusion about what's gonna happen and
once you start honing in on that that's
an opportunity for learning and you're
often not the expert that you think you
are
[Music]